Đại vì nay, Rui là xuống người thịt mạng gió động đất đã lên đến chính trong 2 mình người hơn 3 người và trong 6 người khác bị thương.
Đà hơn 2 ngày chua qua, người dân và các đội cứu hộ cứu nạn đang lộ lực tìm kiếm những người còn sống sốt.
Bì mắt kẻ trửi đồng đồ nát trong khi đó thì các đội cứu hộ cút tế và hàng vị trợ đã lên tục được trên 2 tới hiện trường để cứu trợ các bạn nhận của phụ đồng đất này.
Đà hơn 2 ngày sau được cái cây cây cây cây cây lạ.
Vậy thế giới lạ dùng hơn 2 người, lạ dùng ở cây cây cây thông đến để tục mình kiếm những người sống sốt.
Ví mắt kẻ trửi đồng đối tâm.
Đại băng nào nạn.
3 tụi, 3 đạt nhìn được 1 chân của nạn.
P цен trong những người khoảng 1 mình, trong những khoảng 1 mình.
Như quyết giân đạm thật khoải trên lợi tình tức của mình hơn.
Mình sẽ có thể đưa ra.
Chúng tôi cần sử dụng đường.
Hãy vừa hãy vừa hãy vừa.
Chúng tôi đã mất nhật của các không có nước nào để đi.
Điều được điện tâm ông muốn, là con trái tô đối với sạch hỏi giảm đường.
Sù cho khoảng 2 trong tình trạch nào này.
Tụi vẫn tình trạch khoảng 3.
Tụi có gì mà người hãy đến dụi trong tối.
Vinh còn nhiều người sống só cho khắc tà nhạc.
Chúng tôi không có đúng là người đưa họt sáng lại.
Vinh còn nhiều người đưa họt sáng lại.